this therapy is so stupid I'm just a
working class guy and I resent you I
understand that about you I want to know
why you are oh really oh okay Mr doctor
I have two treatments for you dumb face
idiot idiot first I am going to raise my
voice
all right ah it's still not doing it for
me though I feel like I need something a
little stronger all right well I'm gonna
try strategy too and what's that oh it's
physical violence
oh ow
Chief oh that one hurts I'm ready to
better myself well you know me I love
physical violence hey guys this is the
end of this game before I wrap up the
video I want to ask you what you think
is the most overused therapist you think
it's strategy one the therapist has a
breakdown because the patient is just
too much or do you think that's option
two
violence I look forward to seeing your
choices
[Music]